elle va passer un tout autre sujet on va
parler jardinage avec sylvie la menacer
sa chronique
c'est l'opération parole de génie qui
démarrent à partir de ce samedi et pour
ça on va rejoindre civile a una depuis
un jardin de guyancourt alors une fois
n'est pas coutume on retrouve sylvie
holenda la directrice divine tourisme
alors on vous retrouve en extérieur
d'habitude vous êtes sur le plateau de
tv fil pour nous parler des idées
sorties et là c'est nous qui sortons
pour parler d'une opération qui va se
dérouler du 8 au 30 septembre au niveau
des yvelines et on est dans un jardin ce
n'est pas un hasard et non puisque nous
organisons à l'occasion du mois de
septembre de la rentrée une
manifestation qui s'appelle parole de
jardinier effectivement ce jardin
figurent parmi les participants on peut
le visiter le 15 sept on peut dire que
c'est le jardin d'angle de fausses d'un
jardin exotique qui se trouve à
guyancourt 8 rue des graviers comme ça
on aura donné toutes les toutes les
informations il ya de multiples espèces
de plantes très complexe à découvrir ici
dans ce jardin donc de fo le 15 sept ans
et comme vous l'avait dit il ya il ya
énormément de sites a visé à 46 en tout
on peut visiter pendant tout le mois de
septembre
c'est ça il ya quarante-six sites et
donc 200 animations au total donc il ya
de quoi s'occuper pendant ce mois de
septembre
alors c'est une manifestation qui est
les samedis et les dimanches bien sûr
donc on espère qu'il va faire beau
avec desjardins qui représentent
différentes thématiques donc celui-là
représente une thématique et ambiance
zen exotique avec également les jardins
de lily qui sont à saint-rémy l'honorer
donc voilà plusieurs thématiques
il ya les jardins privés classique où on
vous l'échangera les bonnes pratiques
puisque je rappelle que ça n'est pas une
visite
de jardin classique cette manifestation
mais c'est un lieu d échanges
d'expériences de bonnes pratiques même
parfois de troc aux plantes et le
jardinier qu'ils soient professionnels
ou amateurs va discuter en fait et
dialoguer avec les visiteurs en lui
montrant un peu toutes ces réalisations
voilà la thématique un peu global de la
manifestation c'est ce qui vous a donné
envie la montée de la créer cette
manifestation alors que cette espèce de
volonté d'échangé ça alors parce que
pourquoi ça parce que on se rend compte
qu on est souvent cloisonnés dans sa
ville et puis on discute juste avec ses
voisins et puis c'est tout mais on a
besoin des changes de plus en plus c'est
de ce sont des périodes difficiles on a
besoin de parler s'exprimer dialoguer et
donc c'est pour ça qu'on a créé ça et
pourquoi dans les jardins tout
simplement parce que le jardinage c'est
une pratique de loisir important pour
les français c'est la deuxième pratique
de loisirs des fruits et les français
ont la main verte ça c'est sûr voilà
vous la vidéo on peut visiter des
jardins privés comme celui de m de fond
ici puis le jardin des oliviers 6
éthique voilà aussi un jardin
chinois he has any et on peut aussi
visiter d'autres types de jardins
voilà alors il ya les jardins privés un
peu plus classique
madame le ruyet qui est une dame qui
montre un peu comme on fait le bouturage
et on repartira peut-être même avec des
graines
il y a également le jardin de virginie
le jardin de madame rica enfin plein de
jardins privés qui ouvre il suffit
d'aller voir un peu la liste et le
programme pour découvrir tout ça il ya
des jardins qui proposent des
découvertes rare exceptionnel
c'est le cas du désert de red steel se
trouve à chambourcy ses cadres de
l'arboretum de chèvreloup également il
ya des ateliers pour enfants mais aussi
parce que c'est important on peut y
aller en famille dans ses jardins il y
en a qui sont un petit peu plus pointu
en terme de découvertes mais il ya des
découvertes pour les enfants des
ateliers pour les enfants alors là c'est
la ferme de gally le château de breteuil
les jardineries poulain le domaine de
madame elisabeth donc plein de plein de
choses à faire et aussi des jardins au
naturel qui qui propose deux mois rose
et ses plantes d'économiser l'eau
le compost naturel les engrais naturel
voilà là aussi proche de saint quentin
en yvelines enfants en tout cas à saint
quentin en yvelines ya aussi le domaine
de port royal des champs qui est à magny
les hameaux
voilà le domaine de port royal des
champs vous propose de découvrir les
potagers tout ce qu'il ya où les jardins
partagés également
donc il y aura des visites guidées qui
sont très intéressante à port royal
également il ya des jardins municipaux
oui il ya des jardins municipaux qui
participent à l'opération
et c'est extrêmement variés dont il y en
a pour tous les goûts un des jardins
familiaux aussi que l'on peut découvrir
donc vraiment tout le monde peut s'y
retrouver dans cette opération qui se
déroule donc tous les week-ends beaucoup
peut occuper tous ses week-ends du mois
de trouver un gars comme des événements
phares oui alors l'écusson de mon parti
des éléments phares effectivement qui
sont les dimanches les événements phares
c'est forcément
au parc du château de versailles puisque
notre parrain de l'opération ce n'est
autre qu'alain barrabes jardiniers en
chefs qui a écrit énormément de livres
sur les jardins qui adore son métier qui
le fait partager très très bien et donc
c'est lui qui fera visiter les jardins
des trianon personnellement donc cesser
notable puisque ça n'arrive que très
rarement
ensuite nous avons des fermes de gally
où il y à des ateliers pour les enfants
et puis on pourra rencontrer jusqu'à 45
professionnels aussi qui viennent
échanger et qui sont là à gali pour pour
partager leur passion avec des grands
paysagistes des grands jardinier qui
viennent raconter tout ce qu'ils font au
grand public la joie mais aussi de leurs
pratiques agricoles
bien sûr c'est pas bio mais c'est même
une de large pratique assez de gally
dans la journée pour y passer la journée
entière consommer sur place les produits
de la ferme de gally donc on sait que
c'est quand même une grosse découverte
qui permet de se sortir de chez soi et
d'être dans un environnement
exceptionnel quand même le la semaine
suivante
alors la semaine suivante ce potager du
roi on revient à versailles l'ancien
voilà et là c'est ce sont les
paysagistes et jardiniers qui font
découvrir aux visiteurs les légumes les
fruits également et puis on peut les
acheter si on veut à la sortie et puis
les préparations aussi qu' avec avec ses
légumes et ses fruits et puis il y aura
des conférences également donc
extrêmement variés je le répète et on
finit le 30
et voilà avec donc deux dernièrement
événement phare c'est notre les sites
les plus visités voilà c'est toi et pas
que des animaux à thoiry non non non
touahri sais c'est très large en termes
de l'offre touristique puisqu'il ya
effectivement la réserve zoologique qui
a le parc à pied on découvre les animaux
il ya le parc du château là
effectivement il ya des fleurs donc ce
sont les jardiniers et les comte et la
comtesse de la panne ou ce qu'ils feront
découvrir leurs parcs pour lesquelles il
serait extrêmement passionné il ya le
château aussi qu'on pourra à l'occasion
voir et puis à large des petites bêtes
est donc large des petites bêtes c'est
une nouveauté de la rentrée
on pourra y découvrir des espèces de
batraciens d'insectes donc c'est encore
tout nouveau et très différent de ce
qu'on a pu découvrir ailleurs donc là
c'est le 30 septembre sa cause il y aura
ainsi l'opération spéciale de jardiniers
dont qui démarre le 8 septembre
merci de vida de nous en parler on vous
retrouve comme la saison dernière tous
les quinze jours sur le bateau théophile
le vendredi pour nous donner les idées
sorties sur le département
donc un jour vous viendrez me rejoindre
en plateau voilà d'akio plus dehors
l'accord plusieurs de ces sympathiques
ceci dit fait beau et on est dans un
jardin c'était très sévère ça dure mais
tout à fait donc parole de jardiniers
c'est du 8 au 30 septembre et pour vous
donner un avant goût
je vous propose de regarder ce reportage
tourné à l'occasion de la soirée
inaugurale c'était mercredi soir le
jardinage et le deuxième loisirs
préférés des français après les plaisirs
de la table alors si vous avez l'esprit
curieux et si vous voulez arpenter des
jardins d'inattendu débute ce samedi et
jusqu'au 30 septembre
l'opération parole de jardiniers 46
participants des serres du château de
versailles aux sites de particuliers
comme celui dans de faux à guyancourt où
le jardin chinois de willy à saint-rémy
l'honorer visite conseil échanges sont
au programme ce mercredi soir avait lieu
la soirée inaugurale dans les jardins du
petit trianon à versailles
l'occasion d'apprendre que les jardins
ont toujours existé 2000 ans avant
jésus-christ qui s'était d'abord
l'expression du pouvoir avant de devenir
un lieu de philosophie et lors de cette
visite nous avons demandé à deux
éminents amoureux des jardins quel était
le jardin de leurs rêves
alors le jardin
mais rêve c'est celui qui est au bout du
jardin parce que le principe du jardin
romantique c'est que tous vous permet
d'accéder par les yeux un endroit plus
loin où est le bonheur et c'est ça le
jardin romantique c'est que le bonheur
est toujours un peu plus loin
moi j'ai rien de mon rêve il n'existe
plus jeune mon rêve c'était de gérer mon
grand père
j'avais un grand père qui était un homme
délicieux qui cultivaient des légumes
cultivés au garde-à-vous des poireaux
qui parait-il avait un goût de noisette
c'était vraiment le jardin qui était le
jardin de mon enfance et malheureusement
mon grand père a disparu et avec lui son
jardin donc le jardin de mon rêve c'est
un peu le jardin du grand-père de la
même union en province un jardin qui est
sans prétention qui est beau qui est
bien et que l'on quitte à regret dans
les jardins j'ai envie de dire personnel
d'alain baraton il ya quelle fleur mais
y'a pas grand chose car j'ai la chance
d'en avoir un dans le parc il y à une
pelouse il y à une chaise longue
il ya un parasol car je déteste arrêté
sous le soleil et il n'y a surtout pas
de fleurs parce que les gens à pomas et
du robot